so to start tonight's show ladies and
gentlemen while we Wrangle the comedian
from next door I think you guys know
what happens here you guys are fans of
the show correct well we're going to
start it how we always do you guys know
the words to this
song this is on ktim
everybody a brand new 60 second from the
great
hello
a lot of woke people nowadays are saying
that you can't be racist to white people
what so I'm supposed to be nice to
them if I can't be racist to white
people then why do their thin little
lips start
quivering and I can see their butth
holes pucker up cuz they have no butt
cheeks feel bad for white people maybe
if they didn't kill all the Native
Americans they wouldn't have to take
hip-hop dance classes to feel better
about themselves
[Music]
I love watching Fox News cuz it makes me
look at Mexicans
differently now when I see a Mexican I
just want to document
them that's my problem with Mexicans not
enough paperwork
involved sometimes I'll just hand them a
receipt um but yes uh lot of uh crazy
things happening um I think it's [__]
up that uh gay marriage is Le in
Texas but weed
isn't sometimes I'll be like man I
really wish I could smoke a joint but I
guess I'll suck a dick
instead thank you there you go Hans Tim
with a little Mind Eraser of a closer
there at the end one good closer makes
us forget that the 55 seconds before
that wasn't that
strong well not anymore it was like
observational comedy without any good
observations
white people don't have an ass yeah a
little bit and do all white people have
thin lips Hans they qu not you Tony
that's right not me
Tony I do do Asian people have thicker
lips than white people is that a thing I
hope so uh it's very sad how thin your
lips are no I uh I I don't notice lips
that much huh I didn't understand the
answer me neither I would like to buy a
vowel
um yeah I think white people are great I
was just poking fun you know I make fun
of everyone yeah but you're making [__]
up you're really funny I'm a fan of I've
watched you on the show and I love the
closing joke it's just that a comedian
who's been in it if you're going to do
observational comedy you got it you
can't just make [__] up well don't you
think it's a stereotype that white
people have thin lips I don't I don't
think never heard that I mean we
comparing it Lisa Rena once said to me
she said
Howie if you're going to make jokes no
that was see I made a reference and I
got as much laughter as you did so maybe
it's not your fault maybe it's the room
I often blame the
room this time it's not so much the
room uh so thin lips uh Mexicans
documented you give them a what did you
say a receipt yeah I just want to give
them paperwork because it's a document
yeah okay the last one remember the last
one yeah do that good everyone loved
that one they really did let's focus on
that um you should have open with that
and closed with it if it ain't broke
don't fix it just one joke all the way
through people can't get enough of
sucking
dicks quit while you're ahead no pun
intended it is true
uh stop doing that
Michael so uh enough with the the set
Hans tell us about what's going on in
your real life that's always the most
interesting thing about you let's find
out what's going on this week I've been
having a great real life um I've been uh
to Appleton Wisconsin recently which
doesn't sound as cool oh oh a lot of
thin lips up there a lot of the thin
lipped people if you know what I mean a
lot of the people with those barely
canum
lips the whites were you at a cheese
festival I was actually uh pursuing my
career that's kind of where my career is
at right now as Appleton um but yes
comedy yes ComEd Appleton you did comedy
yeah Skyline Comedy Club the sky was it
in a tower was it in a it was pretty
high up like third floor or the skyline
the skyline of Wisconsin yeah the
skyline of Wisconsin not that high how'd
it go it went fantastically um I do any
of this material there uh I tried to
avoid any of the material I did here
tonight but uh I did a lot of old stuff
which uh you know talking about Bill
Clinton and Monica Linsky oo topical
very good no no better time than
2023 but I went up there I'd be like is
there any black people in the audience
and sometimes there'd be no one no black
people there and be like good a perfect
audience um right yeah that makes sense
but if there was a black audience I'd be
like oh the Wisconsin is so gerrymander
that table just became a congressional
district
okay so it's probably better if there
were no black
people one of them is a really good joke
and the other one is about Jerry
mandering everybody I know I love a good
Jerry mandering joke every once in a
while you know those thin lips they love
Jerry mandering yes indeed the old thin
lipped whites I love it okay uh how's
your relationship going this week my
girlfriend's great uh we recently
started doing Acro yoga you know it's
very stressful what is that it's like
where I uh balance her around my foot
and uh try not to get my toes in her
[__] wouldn't that be called [__]
footing don't [__] foot around me that
I try not to [__] foot around my
girlfriend did you have a toe in the
[__] yeah that's interesting that that
was the first thing that you referenced
was there a toe in the [__] and did you
do it on purpose yes whoa and I was the
difference between athletes foot and
chlamydia it's the same thing I got
chyia on my foot right um but yes it's
great uh the way he could just take a
concept and run with
it it's amazing I got
CL just stops you just stopped love
sorry about that no don't apologize for
me yeah don't no apologies Hans anything
else we should know about I know about
your family I've watched you before
doesn't your your father lives overseas
right yes he's a Korean and overseas
he's in Korea yes yes but so is that
tough do you talk to him I haven't in
about 6 months why uh it's just a little
awkward so do you want to call can we
call him now yeah can we call Mr Kim
sure can we do this oh yeah oh I love
this idea Howie thank you where is where
what time is it where he is uh it's
probably around 6:00 a.m. or good
morning we'll we'll leave him a
voicemail he speaks English right yes a
little bit all right this is Dad this is
hans's Dad this is H's dad this is H's
dad this is H's dad would this be
considered Outsourcing
comedy I think so I don't know this is
is it ringing do you have it on speaker
phone yeah put on speaker this is a
Korean ring are you serious no way you
just said or is there a sound turn it up
this this a caca
talk hold on everybody stop are you on
speaker yes hey hi
[Music]
Dad this is Hans your son uh we're on a
we're on a show on YouTube's thrilled
right now um they wanted to talk to you
cuz they I said I didn't talk to you in
a long time so I'm calling you live on
the air right
now hello Mr Kim it's Tony of kill
Tony what
hello hello hello do you think hi do you
think white people have thin lips just
want to see if it's a family thing Sor I
don't understand
oh white people do you know what white
PE do you have white
people
hello hello hi this is amazing Mr Kim
it's Tony have you ever watched Hans do
comedy
before sorry I cannot hear you is this
really what your dad
sounds what does this guy do for a
living what does he a mathematician he's
a mathematician yeah oh here give me the
phone give me the
pH what was
that say that
again I'm a
mathematician yes very good and you know
Hans is a comedian
right yes I know have you ever watched
him on the uh hit show kill Tony
before uh no I
don't interesting you know your son is
wildly successful
correct yes I I I hope
that yes are you are you proud of
him of course I'm proud of
him
wow The Crowd Goes Wild that was the
correct answer Mr Mr Kim can I call you
Mr can I can I call you Mr
Kim yes okay do do you know any of his
jokes do you know his
jokes yeah I I I heard some of them I
want to tell I want him to tell you just
a closing joke from
tonight tell your father that joke do
the joke Hans is going to do a joke and
we want to see this went over well you
should be very proud this is your son
now telling you the closing joke from
tonight and and feel free to laugh right
into the phone if you think it's funny
and don't laugh if you think it's not
funny go ahead go ahead so in Texas it's
weird it's it's horrible that gay
marriage is legal but weed is not
sometimes I'll be like I wish I could
smoke a joint of marijuana right now but
I guess I'll just have to suck a dick
instead I I don't understand that job
oh explain it to him
well yeah it's because uh you can suck a
dick but you uh how do you say penis in
Korean kou kochou you you can't smoke
marijuana but you could lick
coou
funny
what is the
coach
what I I don't know what what Coach K
kou Co K penis penis dick dick
dick there's the
[Applause]
laugh that's what we were looking for
how we bring the world together I didn't
know you you can speak Korean yeah we
can talk Korean yeah coou to you
buddy this so nice it's beautiful the
way you bring Father and Son together
this is this is incredible this is the
first time we've talked to you we've
heard so much about you before Hans is
an absolute star do you uh are you proud
of him for having a white American
girlfriend within
lips he's okay with sucking dick your
girlfriend not so happy about
mind not
specially I I think if he has a
girlfriend that that's fine and that's
good but fight or other things are not
important other things are more
important race is not important race is
not important wow just like
wow race is very important to huh he
must he must get his racism from his
mother how do you say how do you say how
do you say uh vagina uh I actually
didn't learn that one how do you sir how
do you say
[Music]
vagina how do you say vagina in
Korean uh chungo chungo so your son puts
his foot in her
kunjo chunga he puts
and just I want him to know that she's
very
open to your culture so he knows she's
accepting a woman who lets you put her
foot in her cooo is an accepting person
before we let you go Mr Kim one last
question do you have uh do you know any
jokes do you have like a short joke that
you'd like to do for the first time in
Kil Tony history we have you here on
speaker phone do you know do you know
any
jokes uh the joke of you mean one joke
one
joke so I remember one of his jokes
about Martin Luther King's
day but I cannot I cannot
reproduce uh because of because my my
English here's what I'm going to say you
tell the joke you say the joke in Korean
and talk slowly and then your son will
translate it into English for us yes you
can do this is so weird kill Tony is
closed caption it is amazing you do the
joke in Korean and Hans is going to
translate it well Martin Luther King Day
joke has to be good I hope it ends in
the nword let's go
go go
so h h h went to library
on Martin Lu Luther King's uh
day and the library R is
closed
so he can so he he cannot know about
Martin Luther King so can you translate
louder it should be open on Martin Lu
King's day and instead of that
uh uh what was this the library should
be
closed uh Clos the library shouldn't be
closed why can I translate on Hitler's
birthday Hitler's
birthday
ah wow something like that wow the whole
crowd became Asian that was actually
good that was better than your son's
first 50 seconds of his set tonight
thank you sir
Mr Kim thank you so much for talking to
us great your son is absolutely killing
it he's a star he has a full-time career
he's absolutely a stud you raised a
great boy thank you so much what I want
to pay for I want to pay for my my
interview got to go see you later
buddy oh
[__] man that guy knows how to get me to
hang out real quick he started doing the
math yeah exactly a true
mathematician in Maya going to get a PID
for my
interview my lips started to
quiver I could barely tell they're
so Hans what a great way to start the
show you did it again you beautiful
beautiful boy come on the legend Hans
Kim going up against Rick Diaz for
permanent Reg dealership on New Year's
Eve the stream is on sale now killtony
live.com we are first bucket pull has
been pulled